[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه 60 برنامج
اخباريون خاص ومتنوع وبقاع سريعا ومختلف
جدا نحلله الاحداث بابعادها وبعمر وبين
العاجل والمهم نضع امامكم الاهم والصوره
الكامله البدايه من العناوين
واشنطن تحتوي تحديدات ايران بالسفن
المسيره وبرنامج للتغلبي على مسيراتها
حرب الوثائق تدخل مرحله جديده بمختص جرائم
حروب واتهامات وفساد بالجمله
فقط
المهدده بالتعطل عن تسلا وسياراتها
المرتكبه للحوادث حتى في الصين لونسك في
ازمه
اشعلت حروبا واخمدت اخرى ساحره مستديره
نعم لكن
عاوزني
[موسيقى]
ههه
اكبر تهديدا لامني واستقرار المنطقه ياتي
من ايران وبشكل واضح وموفق هكذا تقول
الولايات المتحده ووجهه التهديد اموتنوعه
النووي بالطبع موجود مجلس محافظين وكاله
الدوليه لطاقه الذريه طلب بالتعاون بشان
تحقيقات اثار اليورانيوم ومياه الخليج جزء
اخر من هذا التهديد ولا دليل على ذلك اكبر
من هجمات المستمره اخرها استهدفت ناقله
نفطن قبله عمان ولاجل هذا الامر ولاجل هذه
التحديثات تحضر القرارات الامريكيه قوه
مخصصه للانظمه غير الماهوله في الخليج
القوه 59 التي اعلن عنها الاصول الخامس في
سبتمبر الماضي العمل الماضي ستنشره اكثر
من 100 سفينه مسيره في مياه المنطقه
الاستراتيجيه بحلول العام المقبل
طيبه
القرصنه تجاره البشر الهجمات على السفن
التجاريه والتهريب اكان تهريب سلاح او
مخدرات واكثر تهديدا على المنطقه هي بشكل
واضح وموفق ايران
بسببي خطوره هذه التهديدات الايرانيه فكان
يجب ان تكون المواجهه استثنائيه القوه 59
هي اول قوه من نوعها تابعه للبحريه
الامريكيه تدمج الانظمه غير الماهوله
والذكاء الصناعي بسرعه مع العمليات
البحريه للاسطول الخامس وهو الذي يغطي ما
يقرب من مليونين و500,000 ميلا مربع تشمل
الخليج العربي وخليج عمان البحر الاحمر
واجزاء من المحيط الهندي منطقه
21 الدوله وثلاث نقاط حرجه في مضيق هرمز
قناه السويس وماضي قبل المنزل
من الواضح تماما بالنسبه لنا ان ايران
كانت خلف الهجوم فقد استخدمت المسيرات ومن
خلال التكنولوجيا التي كانت تنشرها في
المنطقه فانها تتسبب بحاله من عدم
الاستقرار وهو ما يشكل مصدر قلق كبير لنا
لكن لحسن الحظ في هذا الهجوم ما من شخص قد
اصيب وفي حقيقه الامر فانه في العام
الماضي وتحديدا في شهر يوليو تعرض شخصان
كان على متن احدى السفن للقتل بنجوم مشابه
لذا هذه العمليات لابد ان تتوقف ولهذا
السبب فاننا ملتزمون بالحفاظ على حضور
بحري مستمر مع شركائنا في المجال البحري
نسوان
لتشتيت الانتباه عن الاحتجاجات الداخليه
في البلاد وتوجيه الانبار التاره بقصف
كردستان العراق وتاره اخرى بمحاولات ارسال
لاسلحه اليمن والتصعيدي هناك وتاره ثالثا
بملف المفاوضات النوويه الذي يموت سريريا
لكن مياه الخليج حاضره ايضا ما تؤججها
طيران بمسيراتها الفاعله في حرب اوكرانيا
وهي جزء من هذا التحديث ولهذا هناك
استراتيجيه اخرى تعمل عليها واشنطن لكنها
لم تفصح عن كامل تفاصيلها برنامجنا
التجريبيا في الشرق الاوسط للتغلب على
المسايرات ولكن لماذا المسيرات تحديدا
لانها تحديد التكنولوجي الاكبر للامن
الاقليمي في رايي الجنرال الامريكي كولالا
حديثنا ان يتماشى مع اعلانا سابقا لوزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي بنجامس نريد احباطها ما
في الايرانيه بصواريخ الكروز او بالمسيرات
والوسيله السعي لتاسيس تحالفا دفاعيا جوي
بقياده واشنطن تل ابيب وطيران في حرب ظل
المامون سنوات
ايران الى الولايات المتحده فعلها المسلسل
الشهير ذا سمسمز مره اخرى توقعا اخر يحدث
خاصه بترشحي الرئيس الامريكي السابق ترامب
وهو الذي رشح نفسه للرئاسه في 2024 هكذا
اظهر في عام 2000 لكن هل انتهى سباق ترامب
الرئاسي قبل ان يبدا الرئيس السابق رفض
نصيحه فريقه بعدم الاعلام حتى ظهور كل
نتائج الانتخابات النصفيه في مجلس الشيوخ
والاعاده في جورجيا في السادس من ديسمبر
فهل علمت ترامب قبل الاعلان بالعثرات
امامه
اولها ازمه الوثائق التي عين لها مدعام
للاشراف على تحقيقاته وزاره العدل جاكسيمت
كانا مختصر ابي جرائم الحروب
الرئيس الحالي هناك من يمشي البيت الابيض
ترامب الذي يلقي اليوم اول خطاب له منذ
اعلان يترشح امام مجموعه من كبار الشخصيات
في الحزب الجمهوريه دون انه مدرك مداره
خسر كثيرا من الداعمين وهذه عقبه ثانيه
امام ترامب رونالدو لودر وهو وريث ثروه
اسلودر والذي يعرف ترامب منذ ايام الجامعه
اعلن الابتعاد عن عالم ترامب ولم يعلن من
سيدعم في 2024 لكنه في الماضي يتبرع لشركه
تابعه لمن لحكم فلوريدا روندي سانتوس الذي
قد يكون ابرز منافس لترامب داخل الحزب
ستيفن شورزمان الجمهوريه البارز الذي اسمه
بلاك ستون هو الاخر انضم للقائمه وحان
الوقت اللي يتجه الجمهوريون الى جيلا
جديدا من القاده وهكذا تصرح والدعم الذهبي
الرئيس السابق مسؤوليه الموجه الحمراء
التي لم تتحقق ابدا في 2022 واضاف للقائمه
خسائر 2018 و2020
يتزايد الجدل والانقسام بين الجمهوريين في
الكونغرس بعد نتائج انتخابات التشديد
النصفي التي وصفت بالضعيفه والفاشله لعدم
حصول موجه حمراء كما كان متوقعا عدد من
الجمهوريين يرون ان الحزب لم يستفيد من
التضخم ومن تراجع شعبيه الرئيس والتاريخ
الذي يلعب غالبا ضد حزب الرئيس ويلقون
باللاوم على ترامب بسبب الاداء السيء لمن
رشحهم في المقابل ينتقدوا جمهوريون اخرون
زعيمهم في مجلس الشيوخ
الذي حمله ترامب مسؤوليه الفشل في السيطره
على المجلس
انقسام ازداد وضوحا بعد اعلان ترامب عن
ترشحه بين معارضه ومؤيد ومن حاول النائيه
بانفسهم حتى تتضح الصوره اكثر بعد انتهاء
جوله الاعاده في جورجيا واكتماله فرز
الاصوات بالنسبه لمجلس النواب
بعت يوم قال الكاتب والمؤلف البريطاني
جورج اورويل ما من احد امسك بزمام السلطه
وهو ينوي تخلي عنها مره اخرى ويبدو انها
خطه دونالد ترامب في العوده الى الرئاسه
رغم القضايا التي تلاحقه تعكس واقعيه هذه
الحاله بدقه كبيره ترامب رفضها هزيمه 2020
ترك البيت الابيض على ورقه فوضى اعمال
الشغب العاني ففي حادثه الكابيتل وهذه
عقبه ثالثا امامه واليوم هو السبب في
الانقسام الجمهوري بعد انتخابات النصفيه
شكل فيها ان كانوا فوز سبايدر اختباراتا
اساسيا للمرشحين
الجمهوريين بتاييد ودعم ترامب السياسي
الاداء او بالاحرى النتائج كانت اقل من
التوقعات لاكتساحا احمر وان حصلوا على
اكثريه مجلس النواب لكنها كانت طفيفه
بينما عدد كبير من متبنيين نظريه تزوير
الانتخابات 2020 المدع احنا عملنا ترامب
غسلوه في الولايات الرئيسيه لكنه شهيه
ترامب اللي كسب جوله الرئاسيه جديده وشعله
الشعبيه اقوى الشعبيه اقوى من ان تطفئها
معارك صغيره خاصه لازال كما يقول البعض
انه الوحيد القادر على مواجهته يسار عنيد
وادي كلي
رز
[تصفيق]
لمرحله المجابه هلا سيرشح الجمهوريون من
يعرف الديمقراطيون انهم يستطيعون هزيمته
هذه روايه وروايه الاخرى تقول ان
الديمقراطيين يلعبون على اسقاط ترامب من
الداخل كيف يضعفون سيطرته على الحزب هو
يسلطون الاضواء والاعلام على مرشح
نجمهوريا
من المشهد السياسي الامريكي الى الابد على
ما يبدوته فهل تنجح اذا كان رصيد ترامب
الشعبيه
رئيسا شعبيته
الرئيس لا يملك الخيار الكلمه للحزب وعدم
ترشحه سيفقده واحزبه اهتمام الاعلام
والكونغرس والجمهور الا اذا تحول التركيز
على مرشح جديد وبالعرف السياسي سيصبح بيضا
بطه عرجاء اذا تخلى عن سباق 2024
للتوضيح المصطلح يشير الى فتره ان التعقب
انتخابات التجديد النصفي وغالبا ما يعجز
فيها الرئيس عن فعل اي شيء ان تشريعيه
كونه يفقده اغلبيه احد المجلسين على الاقل
وهي حقيقه ادركها رؤساء امريكا منذ العام
ويدركم خطورها المحيطين المحيطون اليوم
التخلي عن الترشح قد يعني اعترافا ضمينيا
بالفشل وفقدان القدره على المنافسه وكبه
الخصم حتى الان لم يقدم بعد اعلانه الرسمي
لكنه لما حلي ذلك
اي اي انسان
لرئاسه الحزب الديمقراطي حاكمته
اعلنت انها لن تنافس على الرئاسه
لا يكون لسبب واحد والعهده على مايكل
فايبر استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
لا يريد ان يشتت وسائل الاعلام عن ادارته
والاجنده التي يعمل بتحقيقها خاصه تلك
التي يتطلب تمريرها عبر الكونجرس لكنها
سحر بيضا قد ينقلب ضده توجيه البوصله الى
الداخل يضعه تحت المجهر وهذا تحديدا يخدم
خطاطه الجمهوريين فتحت هذه القبه وبعد حسن
نتيجه مجلس النواب بدا الحزب الجمهوريه
تسديده اولى ضرباته لراس الهرم
الديمقراطيه
عاد ملف الفساد يلاحق نجل الرئيس الابن
وهي الوسيله والاب هو الغايه بدءا من
ملاحقتي هانتربوي مساله اخرى يتطلع
الجمهوريون لوضع حد لها وتعارض قطط الرئيس
وحزبه سياسه الشيك على بياض السخيه
بالنسبه للمساعدات الاوكرانيه وعلى الارجح
انها ستتوقف معركه الحدود الاولى من معركه
اوكرانيا الحسبه جمهوريه طبعا المتوقع
كذلك ان يقضي ان يقضي الاعضاء الجمهوريون
ساعات طويله بكتابه تشريعات مناهضه للصين
الحرب مع الصين التجاريه طبعا بالدرجه
الاولى بعكس الديمقراطيين بدفع الجمهوريين
لتعزيز ضوابط التصدير اولا للحد من تسرب
التكنولوجيا وثانيا لحمايه حقوق الملكيه
الفكريه وبالنتيجه ستتطلب المواجهه مع
الصين اخفضه سقف المعايير البيئيه زياده
امريكا الاقتصاديه خط احمر لكن كل هذا
سياتي على حسابي ملف المناخ ويدفع باصدام
كبير مع الحزب الديمقراطي وهذا يقودنا
للحديث عن ازمه الطاقه مخزون امريكا من
الديزل المحدد واسعار الوقود مضطربه جدا
والى ارتفاع وحل المشكله سيكون بتامين
طاقه من مصادر لا يفضلها الديمقراطيون
وتاتي على حساب قضيه الاحتباس الحراري اذا
ملفات اخرى ستفتح جبهات الحرب في اروقه
الكونجرس والحرب ستتحول الى كرنفال ساخن
ومصير اعظم دوله لن يكون في احسن احواله
اذا تباعدت الرؤى وضاقت مساحه الخلاف
البناء بين الحبيبين
[موسيقى]
السلام
من واشنطن ينضم الينا عبر الزومبي بس
العضو الجمهوريه السابق في مجلس النواب
الامريكي اهلا بك اذا التحديات امام ترامب
كبيره وكبيره جدا ويعزو الكثيرون ترشحه
المبكر الى خوفه واقلقه من الانتخابات
المقبله ويستحضر الكثير من الجمهوريين
اداؤه السياسي يلومونه في هجوم الكابيتال
هناك الكابتل وهناك التحقيقات المفتوحه
والاهم ان هناك مطالبات من داخل الحزب
بتغيير النمط والوجوه من اين يبدا ترامب
سعيد عليك السؤال اذا التحديات كبيره امام
ترامب سواء من داخل الحزب الجمهوريه هذه
الموجه التي تطالب
بوجوه جديده ونهج جديد هناك التحقيقات
بشان ترامب وايضا هناك هذه الموجه التي لم
تتحقق الموجه الحمراء التي لم تتحقق في
الانتخابات النصفيه تحديات كبيره ومن اين
سيبدا ترامب
يبدا الان
وعلى وتر على تحقيقات المستمره
واحداث السادس
المرشحين الذين يمكن ان يختارهم للترشح
الحي المرشحين الجمهوريين الذين اختارهم
لم يكن اختارهم ناجح جدا
ومرشحين الذين لم يكن على صلبه نداءهم
افضل من الذين اختارهم ذلك
الجيل الجديد من امثاله
جديده همم الانتخابات الجديده لذلك فهو
مشكله العمر وحتى
او
الجمهورينا لهم عليه نتائج السيئه في
الانتخابات النصفيه الموجه الحمراء
اذا من المعلومه الان ان المعركه امامه
ترامب هي يعني معركه جمهوريه جمهوريه ولكن
يبدو ان ترامب سيركز بشكل اكبر على
ديسانتس بسبب شعبيته التي اكتسبها الشعبيه
المتزايده امام ديسانتس حظوظه ترامب
حاضر
ولكن
احتياطي من الدعم عبر البلاد
واعتقد بان الحزب الجمهوري مستعد للتغيير
الى اعمار
والتحقيقات المحيطه بيتشامبك
عن شخص
الجمهوريه السابق في مجلس النواب الامريكي
مشاهدينا رغم الطراب الاسواق الرقميه لاعب
جديد مشهور يدخل يدخل اليها في الساعه بعد
دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اذا افلست بانانس
يعني هذا انتهاء اللعبه في اسواق العملات
الرقميه هذا هو راي مؤسس عمله دوت كوم
بالمركز السوق مطرب للغايه مليانه و700
مليون دولار تدفقت من محفظتي باينس كدليل
على وجود الاحتياطي لكن التحويل اثار
التساؤلات ووضع بايلانس تحت الرصد لماذا
ربما بسبب حديث سابق لرئيسها التنفيذي اذا
قامت احدى المنصات ابي تحويل من مبالغ
كبيره من اموال العملات الرقميه دون تحديد
عناوين المحفظه فهذه علامه استفهام
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا هذا نوريال روبيني خبيره
اقتصادي يتنبا بالازمه الاقتصاديه
العالميه عام 2008 ويتنبا اليوم بسيناريو
مشابه بالاسوا اما هذا الشخص فهو صوره
تسيدت العناوين وظهوره يمثل رعبا اقتصاديا
من ازمه في سوق العملات الرقميه قد تمدوا
الى القطاع المصرفي التقليدي تماما كما
حصل مع بنكرس في بدايه ازمه 2008 القصه
شركه اف تي اكس احد رموز اتداول الرقمي
وسام بانكمان هو مديرها العام الشركه
اعلنت افلاسها مليارات الدولارات تبخرت
وباتمان باتا بحكم الواقع ملياردير
المفلسا لكن كيف اصبح بنك مان ملياردير
اصلا قصته القصيره للغايه نحن في عام 2017
القيود التي كانت تضعها البنوك اضافه الى
الطلب المرتفع على البيتكوين جعل
اليابانيين ان ينتظرون لاسابيع قبل الحصول
على العملات الرقميه والنتيجه ارتفاع
ثمنها بالنسبه 10% مقارنه بالاسعار
الامريكيه وهنا
ظهر بنك مان اسس شركه الميدان للابحاث
شركه بوظيفه واحده هي استغلال تفاوت
الاسعار بين اليابان وامريكا لتحقق هذه
الشركه الناشئه ارباح تصل الى 20 مليون
دولار في اليوم
لا تشرين ثم اسس افتي اكس التي التاهمت
حصص المنافسين الاقدم في سوق التداول
العملات الرقميه وبالتوازي تحول سامبا الى
اغنى شاب في العالم
لثروه بلغت شهر مارس الماضي 26 مليارا
و500 مليون دولار
نشاطاته بنك مان ارتبطت مؤخرا بعمليات
تمويلا بضماناتنا وهميه مرتبطه اساسا
بالعملات المشفره وهو استنساخ لما حصل مع
الاستثمارات الوهميه التي كانت السبب في
انهيار سوق الرهن العقاري عام 2008 الفريق
اليوم هو ان سوق العملات الرقميه غير خاضع
لاي تنظيما صار وهو ما يزيد من قوه الصدمه
بنك مان اقرب شركته الاخرى الميدان 10
مليارات دولار لكن ماذا عن الضمانات
هنا الاشكال الضمنات لم تكن الا عملات اف
تي التي اطلقتها اف تي اكس كل هذا لم يكن
كافيا لتدمير الثروه بنك مان الرصاصه
الرحمه اطلقت من اشد منافسين منصه باينس
مدير المنصه اعلن التخلصه من عمله اف تي
اكس مشددا على عدم التسامحه مع من
يتلاعبون بسوق العملات الرقميه وهذا في
اشاره لبنك مان
تصريحاته تشاود تسببت بحاله لدى
المتعاملين الذين قدموا طلبات السحب بلغت
قيمتها 5 مليارات دولار وهو ما لم يستطع
البنك من الالتزام به اعلان الافلاس بات
امرا حتنيا امتدى الاثر اللي سوق العملات
المشفره تراجعت باينس لتعلن تقديم خطه
انقاذ لمنافستها الاصغر في اكس لكن الامر
اتعدى قدره باينس على المساعده
وهنا يؤكد براء ان التخلص من منافسه بارز
يعد اهم من الاضرار التي قد تصيب السوق
اسواق العملات الرقميه منذ نشاتها كانت
متقلبه وعدوها الرئيسي هو انعدام ثقه
الناس امرنا ان يحدث الان بالطبع فقاعه
عمليه وان طال عمدها وهكذا يراها
المعارضون لكن تمت معارضين مختلفين هذه
المره نشطاء البيئه فما هي العلاقه بين
العمله الالكترونيه
والاحتباس الحراري من يرغب بقى في امتلاك
البيتكوين من يرغبون في ذلك ليسوا مضطرين
لشراءها
يمكنها افتراضيه طبعا كل ما يجب فعله هو
حاسوب لحلي مساء الرياضيه ومعقده
وكامكافاه تصرف عملات رقميات مقابل ذلك في
البدايه كانت العمليه اقل تعقيدا وبطبع
اقل استهلاكا للطاقه واما الان ف
المنافسات تستلزم وتسخير عددا كبيرا من
المتطوره لحل المساله اولا وبالتالي طاقه
كهربائيه اكثر للتوضيح فقط من اجل تعدين
3600 وحده بتكوين الثانويه تستهلك اجهزه
الكمبيوتر كميه كبيره معادله لاستهلاك
الدول مثل هولندا وباكستان سنويا
المستثمرون ايلجؤون لتغيير اجهزه
الكمبيوتر في كل مره بحجه ضروره عدم تاخر
التكنولوجيا اكيد وهذا ما يزيد من حجمه
النفايات الالكترونيه الخطره وارتباط
العملات الرقميه بالاحتباس الحراري تسبب
في انخفاض قيمتها مدى هذا واضحا عندما
اعلنت شركه تسلا تعليقه قبول البسكويت
كملتي سدادا قبل ان تستخدم الطاقه النظيفه
في تعديل نصف العملات الرقميه على الاقل
اذا نكمل هذا الملف مع ضيفي الدكتور محمد
عبد المطلب الشريف المؤسس لشركه اكس بي
اهلا بك اذا
قبل ان ندخل في اف تي اكس هناك الان خوف
كبير على سوق العملات بشكل كامل بايضا كان
قال مرارا وحذر من ان العملات الرقميه
وسوق العملات الرقميه يعدوا تهديدا للامن
القومي الخزانه الامريكيه الان تتحدث عن
الافتقار للشفافيه في هذه السوق فهل هذا
يضيق الخناق على هذه العملات بشكل عام
مما لا شك فيه طبعا
المشكله الاساسيه بقى لنا فتره هي اهميه
وجود تشريعات ووجود رقابه للاسف الرقابه
كانت دائما متجهه في محاوله السيطره على
السوق العملات الرقميه وليس على كيفيه
اداره العملات الرقميه وده المشكله اللي
حصلت فيها نحن وقعنا فيها اليومين دول لان
اللي حصل مؤخرا زي ما هنتكلم ده كان سوء
اداره ده ما لوش علاقه
باي حاجه لها علاقه بالعراق المشفره ده
كان عمل اجرامي بحث زيه زي ما في احداث
اخرى حصلت في باقي الاسواق العالميه
اف تي اكس الان
وبتكلم على النقطه السؤال اللي حضرتك
سالتيني لان
فق بشكل كامل وهنا هنا المشكله يعني هل
انت مع احتمال انهيار السوق يعني هناك
عزوف وفي نفس الوقت هناك من يدخل ايضا
هناك رموز ووجوه تدخل الى هذه السوق مثلا
كريستيانو رونالدو بالان افتيس وشاهدنا
الكثير من المسؤولين ومن كثير من الوجوه
والشخصيات العالميه التي تشجع هذه السوق
ده حقيقي ولا اهم من الشخصيات العربيه
دخول شركات كبيره زي فيزا ومستر كارد
مؤخرا والتحالفات اللي عمالين يعملوها مع
شركات في العملات المشفره ده بيوضح بقوه
اهميه العملات المشفره بالاضافه الى
البنوك المركزيه الكثيره اللي عايزه تطلع
عملات مشفره خاصه بها لو بنتكلم على
تكنولوجيا التكنولوجيا موجوده لتستمر لو
بنتكلم على السوق طبعا السوق هيصب بنوع من
الخمول ولانحضار مؤقتا زي ما حصل في جميع
الاسواق العالميه وانس ان في لحظه ما في
مشكله زي اللي حصلت دي فبالتالي هو هيتاثر
ان انا شك فيه لكن هيختفي احتلال ضئيل جدا
جدا ان الصوره اللي انتم تشوفها يختفي همم
بالعكس الحلول اللي العملات المشفره
بتقدمها حتى الاول نهارده همم مجرد نظريا
هي حلول قويه جدا وبتساعد المنظومه
العالميه
نعم اشكرك على الجزيره شكرا على الدكتور
محمد عبد المطلب الشريك المؤسس للشركات
اكس بي
ورغم هذا الخطر الذي تحدثنا عنها دخل لاعب
جديد للسباق نجم الكره البرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو الذي اطلق مجموعه من
الرموز المشفره غير قابله للاستبدال الاس
تي ستكون متاح فقط على باينس اكبر فرصات
العملات المشفره الان في العالم وهذه
الرموز تعتبر بمثابه وثائق رقميه تؤكد
ملكيه اصول الكترونيه لشخص ما
[موسيقى]
هل تستطيعون العيش بلا تويتر
عليكم ربما الاستعداد المنصه قد تتعطل
التطورات تتسارع في تويتر
في احد الاقسام الرئيسيه للشركه هناك ثلاث
مهندسين فقط
اليوم لتغريده على هذه المزرعه الاجتماعي
احتمال عدم الصمود وارد تويتر قد يتعطل
ابي حسب مصادر داخليه لواشنطن بوست ولهذا
الجميع مطالب بحفظ الارشيف ليس فقط تعطل
منصه هو الخطر الاستقالات والتسريح تجعلان
المنصه اكثر عرضه للاختراق والاعطال بحسب
وكاله بلومبيرج ولهذا طالب البيت الابيض
ماسك
اجراءات لحمايه بيانات
على الانترنت
خطرا اخر كبير المعلومات المضلله ماسك حلا
فريقا رئيسا كان مسؤولا عن مكافحه
المعلومات الخاطئه على المنصهره هذا الامر
اجليا في البرازيل الشهر الماضي في خضم
الانتخابات الرئاسيه انتشرت مواضيع
بتغريدات حول ادله وجدتها الحكومه على
تزويلا في النظام الانتخابيه واحد
المعالجين السابقين لخص الامر لبي بي سي
تجربه للجميع ستزداد سوء بسبب الافتقار
الى التوجيه
[موسيقى]
ومن امامي مقري شركه تويتر في كاليفورنيا
ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه حسين توضح حسين
انت هناك منذ ساعات الصباح يعني هذه
الحاله التي تشهدها وشاهدتها منذ الصباح
لو ترصد لنا المستجدات متى سيتم اعاده فتح
المقر الرئيسي لتويتر
تحيه لك يا حنين من المفروض ان يتم اعاده
فتح المقر الرئيسي الذي يظهر خلفي هنا في
سان فرانسيسكو يوم الاثنين ولكن في
الحقيقه هناك رسائل متضاربه داخل مؤسسه
تويتر البارحه الى ماسك طالبه برساله
الكترونيه كل موظف يجيد البرمجه اي كتابه
سوفت ويرز كتابه برامج بان ياتي يجتمع معه
على الساعه الثانيه ظهرا وفي الطابق
العاشر في مؤسسه التويتر او شركه تويتر
همم بالفعل حصل الاجتماع وغرد الى الناس
بصوره وهو يجتمع مع موظفيه همم هناك من
يقول الان حنين بان لهم ماسك الان بدا
يلينفه نسيمه بعد اولا همم فصل همم نصف
اعداد موظفي تويتر وتقديم استقاله حوالي
1000 الى 11 موظف يوم الخميس من هؤلاء
وهذا الخطوره عدد كبير من التقنيين
ومهندسين البنيه التحتيه لفراستراكشر
الخاصه بحواسيب وخوادم همم تويتر التي
تعمل بها البعض يحذر من ان الان قد لا
تظهر المشكله للمستخدمين التويتر ما زال
يعمل لا يوجد انقطاع بخدماته ولكن مع المد
الطويله قد اولا نشهد تباطؤ في الخدمه
مشهد همم تباطؤ بتحديث همم جدول الزمني
التايم لاين طبقات
منه ايضا واشنطن بوست نقلا عن مسؤول اشكرك
جزيل الشكر معنا من كلفوني من امام قاره
وتر مراسل العربيه احسان
[موسيقى]
كلوا هذه المشاكل التي ذكرناها لا تاتي
فرادى وانما بالجمله على راس الملياردير
الامريكي الرجل المثقل بهمه
السياره الحديثه الانيقه المتطوره
استدعت اليوم اكثر من 320 الف السياره في
امريكا بسبب مشكلات فنيه واما في الصين
فهناك حوادث بسبب هذه الاعطال وتحديدا
برنامج القياده الذاتي بل وتسببت بمقتل
اشخاص الحادثه الاخيره كانت ماده دسمه
لاطراف التهاجم ماسك وتسلق وتحديد برنامج
القياده الذاتيه الخاص بالشركه دون
بروجيكتري حمله اعلاميه ضد ماسك وبرنامجيه
للقياده الذاتيه الكامله واطلقها الرئيس
التنفيذي اكبر شركه التكنولوجيا شركات
التكنولوجيا في الولايات المتحده
لكن هل تتخيلون انه انفق ملايين الدولارات
لشراء مركبات تسلا واختبار تلك
التكنولوجيا
فاستراتيجيته تعتمد على توثيق الادله ضد
البرنامج
الذاتيه يرتكبوا خطا ان كل دقائق وتستند
في هذه في ذلك على تحليل عشرات الساعه من
لقطه مصوره وللمفارقه ان حادث الصين وهي
بالمناسبه ثاني اكبر سوق لتسلا ياتي قبل
اسابيع من هدفا اعلنه ماسك البدء ببيعه
سيارات تسلا الكهربائيه ذاتيه القياده
بشكل كامل نهايه العالم
ماسكه يحاولوا تحديث التكنولوجيا الخاصه
ببرنامج القياده الذي سيغير العالم على
احد قوله نهجوا الشركات سيساعد على
التقليل او وقف الوفيات الناجمه عن
الاخطاء البشريه على الطرقات غير ان هذا
حتى اللحظه ليس دقيقه
هناك حوادث ووفيات وشكاوه المركبه تتوقف
مبكرا جدا عند الاقتراب من علامه التوقف
وتحاول السير على طرقات المزدحمه دون
الالتفات للاشارات وتارجح ايضا مشكله وهذا
احد المقاطع المصوره التي يقول خبراء انها
مطلقه جدا تظهر كيف يتدخل السائق للسيطره
على النظام الالي وضبطي مسار السياره اكثر
من مره
رغم ذلك يصف ماسك ان نتخلي عن هذه
التكنولوجيا سيكون خطا اخلاقيا فالسؤال هل
يتخلى ماسك عن التكنولوجيا ربما لان يتخلى
وانما قد يجبره القضاء فتسلى تواجه حاليا
تحقيقا جنائيا في الولايات المتحده بشان
هذه المزعم تحقيقات بدات العام الماضي
بحسب روايه تحقيق اخر تواجهه في الصين
تبقى صوره الحادث الاخيره فيها الاكثر
قسوه وتحقيقاته بكين ايضا لم تنتهي بعد
[موسيقى]
همم
حتى في الرياضه هتلر وموصلين في الساعه
بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
اخرى الساحره المستديره تاثيرها ساحر
كسمها رسميا
على اهميته عدم تداخل السياسه بالرياضه
واقرا التاريخ يشيروا لعكس ذلك ودعونا
نعوذ بالزمن العام
1930 اول كاس عالم في التاريخ ونام يلعبون
ان يسمى الاستقلال في منطقه فيديو والحدث
نهائي المونديال الارجنتين ضد المضيف
اوروغواي والاخير كانت تحتفل بمرور 100
عاما على الاستقلال ومن الارجنتين
في النسختين التاليتين
1934 و
1938 قدم مصري الايطالي على انه انتصارا
للفشيه على الايديولوجيات الاخرى ارتدى
اللاعبون زي الاسود كرمزا لدعمهم للحزب
الفاشي وواضبوا على اداء التحيه الفاشيه
قبل المباريات وهذا امر استفاده منه هتلر
لاحقا هذا
في بدايه الثلاثينات ليستضيف الالعاب
الاولمبيه
ولكنها زعيمه رايحه ثالثه لم يكن له شيدا
هذا الملعب بضخمته لاسباب الناريه
اصلا هام في الثوره الجزائريه التي انطلقت
عام
1954 كتبه لاعبوا كره القدم ذهبوا من
فرنسا الى تونس وشكلوا فريق جبهه التحرير
الوطنيه لينطلقوا في جوله عالميه كبرى عام
858 والجوله ساهمت في التعريف بالقضيه
الجزائريه
يعرف يعرف الجميع في كره القدم مصطلحات
حرب مجازيا بالطبع ويدل على شده التنافس
لكن نحن الان في العمل
الحرب
واقعيا حرب المئه ساعه بين دولتين
السلفادور وهندورس والسبب مباراه للكراره
ضحيتها اكثر من ثلاثه الاف
نمرو بالزمن مشاهدينا وصولا الى
1986 مونديال المكسيك التواجهت انجلترا مع
الارجنتين الارجنتين انتصرت وسجل اسطرتها
مارادونا هدفين لكن ما علاقه ذلك بالسياسه
بريطانيا والارجنتين كانتا في حرب
الفوكلاند التي اندلعت قبلها باربع سنوات
وخرج مارادونا بعد المباراه بتصريحات تربط
الرياضه
[موسيقى]
كريم
على اخر في فرنسا زين الدين زيدان الشخص
الاكثر شعبيه في فرنسا وكان ذلك الذي حصل
لها مونديال
1998 حتى ان خطا على تصويت ضد جينري لوبان
2002 وبنته في 2017 وهو امرا يحاول الرئيس
الفرنسي الان امن والماكرون تكراره ايضا
الاحمر
الجيش الفرنسيه
لا فيهم
كارلوس كروش استدعى احدا نجومه سردار
ازمون فما القصه سلطاته الطيران حاولت
الضغط الاستبعاده لماذا دعم الاحتجاجات
الشعبيه هذه ليست المره الاولى التي يثير
فيها لاعبو منتخب ايران غضبا النظام مع
انطلاقه مظاهرات الحركه الخضراء ايضا في
عام 2009 دخل عدد من نجوم المنتخب
الايراني بشاره خضراء في استاد العاصمه
الكوريه الجنوبيه صول قبل ان يختفي بين
الشوطين واشبروا على نزعها بالطبع سويسرا
وصربيا مباراه سياسيه اخرى منتظره جرانيت
تشاكا وشيردان شاكيري اثنين من بين
200,000 سويسري من اصلبي اثاره الثنائي
مشاعره متناقضه خلال المونديال الماضي
فرحه في كوسوفي وغضب في صربيا بعد
الاحتفال بهدفيهما بتقليده شعار النصر
بالراسين الذي يرمز الى ما يطلق عليها
البانيا الكبرى وقبل ذلك باربع سنوات لعام
2014 في بلغراد توقفت مباراه اخرى بين
البلدين على ما يمثل البانيا الكبرى القيا
في الملعب ولاعب صربي امسك بالعلم ما ادى
الى رد فعل غاضب من اللاعبين الالبان
الذين حاولوا انتاعه منه لتبدا المشاجره
وبالتالي اجتياح الجماهير للملعب منتخبات
كره القدم اتعكس الشخصيه الوطنيه لبلادها
وهذا تصريح شهير لوزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
الاسبق امريكا سنجر وفي المجتمعات
اللاتينيه مثلا انتشار الفساد وغياب
الرفاهيه للطبقات الدنيا يجعلان الايمان
ابي ان القدره على الافلات من العقاب ليست
شيئا معيبا للغايه اما في الدول ذات
القوانين على اكثر حجما اوروبا مثلا الامر
مختلف للتدليل على يمكن المقارنه بين
موقفين متشابهين بردود افعال مختلفه في
الفن
1986 استخدم النجم الارجنتيني مارادونا
لاحرازي هدفا يده وهذا الهدف هو الهدف
الشهير كان ضد انجلترا حينها لم يشعر
الارجنتينيون اولا مارادونا بانهم مضطرون
لتبريد الامر وبات هدفا اسطوريا يعكس دهاء
كرويا على الجانب الاخر وصلت فرنسا لكاس
العالم في 2010 على حساب ايرلندا وبفضل
هدف حاسم بعد لمس المهاجم الفرنسيه هنري
بيده الكره مرتين على طرف هنري بخجل بما
فعله ودفعت الفيفا خمسه ملايين ليه
ايرلندا
المنظمه الكرويه الدوليه
[موسيقى]
كثيرا منه يحب اللحوم لكن هل سيتغير طعمها
ان كان هذا اللحم الصناعيه
من الانواع حتى الساعه المقبله انا حنين
الشولي وهذه الساعه 60
[موسيقى]